c'est lille donc je suis là conseillant
aux maxi nation ça va bien une
infirmière qui répond aux questions de
parents d'enfants naissent
il encourage à le faire vacciner la même
scène se reproduit une douzaine de fois
par jour à sainte justine
depuis un an et demi les réactions
normales suite à la vaccination ça
serait d'avoir la fiev
cette fois ci aucun problème le maire
est déjà convaincu le vaccin c'est pour
toi c'est pour ta famille ton conjoint
tes enfants tu te protège toi même mais
tu peux pas mettre un enfant au monde et
pas de protéger mais de plus en plus
souvent les parents hésitent et se
questionne on leur dit que c'est
légitime d'avoir des questionnements on
n'est pas là pour s'opposer ou les
contrarier tout ça donc c'est vraiment
juste de montrer que oui ils ont des
connaissances et voilà ce que n'ont pas
ajouter de plus la principale source
d'information des parents qui hésitent
les médias sociaux a laissé premier
vaccin aussi les trois premiers puis
après ceux à l'iso pas les autres c'est
pourquoi il ya trop de trucs sur
facebook sur les réseaux sociaux des
toutes les enfants malades après les
vaccins que non c'est pas évident comme
parent de naviguer à travers toute cette
information-là l'internet les réseaux
sociaux
donc voilà que notre rôle c'est vraiment
des accompagnants travers tout ça gd
rassurer le plus possible pourtant la
majorité des québécois appuient la
vaccination en 2016 95% des enfants
denain avait reçu tous les vaccins
important et 91 % des enfants de 2 ans
c'est pas mal mieux qu'en 2006 je pense
que c'est bien prévenir leurs enfants
sont en contact avec d'autres enfants
donc moi ça m'inquiète pas mais s'il ya
à peine 2 % des parents contre les
vaccins au québec
ceux qui hésitent sont très nombreux on
dit souvent que les vaccins sont
victimes de leur succès parce que les
vaccins sont tellement efficaces pour
prévenir les maladies bello les gens
plutôt que de s'inquiéter par rapport
aux maladies elles vont s'inquiéter par
rapport au risque des vaccins
moi je suis contre mon fils ils seraient
pas vaccinés maxxi n'est pas tout
pourquoi parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'effets secondaires je trouve sont
souvent malades après avoir été vaccinée
pour freiner ce phénomène
une douzaine de maternité offre
maintenant un programme d'information
sur la vaccination en santé publique qui
a une perception que si le 30 % de gens
qui sont plus ou moins hésitant par
rapport au vaccin s'arrête tout d'un
coup a refusé les vaccins mais rare une
situation grave d'éclosion de problème
de santé publique et ça fonctionne en 18
mois
plus de 20000 parents ont rencontré des
conseillers en vaccination ce qui a
permis de diminuer de moitié le groupe
de parents treiziste
est ce que ça vous êtes avez d'un côté
des gens qui voulaient vraiment pas
changé d'idée on a eu des refus de rend
compte également dans ce temps là on a
juste dit aux parents qui ont respecté
leur décision mais qu'on était
disponible si avait besoin d'en parler
de nouveau sinon ma grondin radio canada
montréal